breaking news overnight u.s backed
syrian forces say they have seized
control of the last pocket of territory
held by the islamic state
in syria the victory puts an end to the
brutal long reign of terror by
isis that once covered large parts of
syria and iraq
charlie dagetta is in northern syria
charlie good morning
good morning and it is a good morning we
got that confirmation from u.s
backed troops here so many were waiting
for a military victory in the final
fight against
isis ending an american-backed battle
that's lasted for more than four and a
half years
president trump's victory declaration
yesterday was only slightly premature
you look
so there's isis and that's what we have
right now
as of last night that's what we have
right now
you guys can have the map
congratulations this morning the syrian
democratic forces raised a flag over
what had been the final scrap of isis
territory in bagooz
the victory came at the end of a week of
heavy fighting against remaining isis
holdouts
hiding out in tunnels and caves beneath
the cliffs sdf
soldiers took us to earlier this week
overlooking the last isis encampment
inside bagooz
the days of the so-called isis caliphate
came to a humiliating
end here in a whimper on a scrap heap in
a village
few syrians had even heard of while the
defeat of isis on the ground is a major
milestone america's allies here say
they're worried it will hasten the
withdrawal
of u.s troops they've been a vital
component of this fight
america's 2 000 ground forces along with
tens of thousands of u.s and coalition
airstrikes that finally brought isis to
a crushing defeat
its five-year reign of terror over more
than 10 million
people the mass executions the utter
brutality finally brought to an
end by sdf soldiers with help from
american allies
now here's the part where we have to say
the end of the caliphate doesn't mean
the end of
isis there may be tens of thousands of
isis supporters who will continue to
pose a threat to this region
but that shouldn't take away from the
importance of today
isis no longer holds an inch of
territory
it can call its own michelle thanks
charlie